ومن جانبها اكد المتحدث باسم البحريه
الاوكرانيه في تصريح خاص بالجزيره انا
اسقاط صواريخ كاليبر التي تطلق من السفن
الروسيه في البحر الاسود اصبح ممكنا بشكل
كبير لكنه قال ان الصواريخ الفرد صوتيه
التي تطلق من قواعد ارضيه تبقى اكبر تحد
للدفاعات الجويه الاوكرانيه
بالنسبه الى الخطر الصاروخي على اوديسا
فهو متفاوت حيث يحرك الاسطول الروسي بشكل
يومي حاملات صواريخ مجهزه بصواريخ كاليبر
التي يحتاج تجهيز اطلاقها الى ما بين خمس
دقائق وسبع واصبح اسقاطها ممكنا بنسبه
كبيره كما هي الحال مع طائرات شاهد ايضا
لكن الخطر الحقيقي هو الصواريخ التي تطلق
من قواعد ارضيه حيث تحلق الصواريخ الفرض
صوتيه فوق اراضي شبه جزيره القرم ويصعب
اسقاطها جدا